it's more than I feel like most of the
challenges I ended up facing we're
brought on me by my own mind like kind
of ignoring what everyone because
everyone has a different perspective
like everyone has their own biases based
on whatever their personal mental
rolodex of experiences are so it's like
some people may judge me for being black
some which ID me for being a woman
Sandra judge me for pigeonhole me to
hip-hop or whatever the case may be
depending on what your particular like
personal perspective is because we see
the world as we are not as it is so who
knows how people see me so I guess just
that battle that internal battle of Xing
out everyone and just kind of like
knowing how I see me
yeah I was actually surprised when I
read some stuff about you but I'm
that you didn't quite good enough for
your song for anything in life yeah
surprising why why did you feel that
I'm really I'm super particular about
I don't know I guess we're our own worst
critic but I'm like the worst worst
worst leg possible like I feel like I
cried when I got my first tee - I'm just
like that person I think are you a bird
over I'm a scorpion with a Pisces moon
which the Scorpio makes me more like
crazy than perfectionist but when
channeled correctly it can turn into
like a search for perfection a dangerous
hold me - you know what's crazy I feel
like the momentum is so natural at this
point because there's what's happening
is this comfortability and women are
opening in terms of feeling powerful cuz
there's so many women that share this
experience in this story I don't think
it's it's gonna need something to keep
it going I think more women are just
gonna feel more comfortable and more
empowered and feeling like they're not
by themselves and they're not
embarrassed and they're not ashamed and
not only just snowballing something
positive and time's up and has this
whole movement help you feel more
confident in your zones in your show
definitely definitely I feel like as a
woman that experience there's a lot of
awkward I don't know instances like in
my entire life like I've had some very
some weird things happened to me so I
think it's very empowering I hear all
these women be super encouraged and
super like empowered and confident and
like just almost I don't know like bossy
like it just just boss energy like it's
very it makes me feel like I have back
up like as a woman no matter where I'm
at like in the world and I feel like I
have any woman's back wherever she is in
the world when I hear about you know
that young girl who got raped and
murdered and Pakistan or like and I hear
about girls being married off at too
young of an age but I just I feel like
no I want a five minute so I want to
speak to this girl I want to hear about
the girl who got found in a freezer
because her friend sent her up to be
murdered and killed and that's right
here in the US and then the police never
went further into that case I feel like
now is the time when all women have each
other's back in an unapologetic like
beautiful loud vibrant way and I'm super
honored to be a part of that
and now your career is on fire
what's what's been the reaction or
thought about when you open three
actually
[Music]
it took me like a day to believe it was
true so and my phone was broken and I
was in London so I thought that like
this was like hypothetical positive
thinking from my manager when he's just
like but um guess what and I'm just like
okay like I was just kind of rolling my
eyes and then the next day I got lots of
my it was so weird I broke my phone my
screen cracked and I got locked out of
my eyes like my iCloud so I couldn't
actually like go onto the internet and
process or even like be grateful out
loud like it was weird I just sit and
Mull it over for 20 hours like a really
long today and it was crazy like I went
through mad different like friends and
crying and like just believe I didn't
really know what to make put family
friends
my mom was literally like she just
honestly feels like being considered at
all like that is winning that is that's
true though like that's the that's what
you my parents my parents watch me not
graduate like over and over again and
they watched me get fired from job and
time and time again and so this I think
it's just like it's cool it's like they
gave this moment to root for their kid
and be hi
to be that kid the GRE start right here
except shoot speech know everything I
write sounds stupid I have to just like
say whatever I think about which would
also maybe sound stupid but I'd rather
like take that chance
and like write something and then be
like prepared and stupid most nominated
female in 2008
you sound like me thank you I'm so
grateful